alors un café joyeuse c'est un concept
en fait ce sont des cafés dans lesquels
vous trouvez 80% des employés qui sont
soit porteurs de d'un syndrome
autistique soit porteur de trisomie 21
donc ça ça fait partie du l'essentiel du
personnel qui sont encadrés par des
managers qui sont donc formés et donc ça
s'appelle le café joyeux il y en a
plusieurs en France il y en a à Lisbonne
à Bruxelles il y a une dizaine en France
et donc celui-ci vient d'ouvrir à parler
de dur le centre commercial porte Saint
Michel plus précisément donc vous pouvez
y aller évidemment prendre un café vous
pouvez y aller déjeuner les cuisines et
faites sur place des produits frais de
saison le centre commercial Paris 2
c'est un peu le temps de la consommation
du paraître et là au cœur de cet endroit
il va y avoir du cœur justement de
l'humain de la chaleur humaine et et un
lieu qui a vraiment du sens